la parole est à Monsieur albéric de
Montgolfier pour le groupe Union pour un
mouvement populaire merci Monsieur
président ma question porte sur le
prochain loi projet loi de finance dont
nous allons commencer l'examen dans
cette hémicycle la semaine prochaine
puisque en août dernier le ministre
Pierre Moscovici et je vais reprendre
ses propres termes avait évoqué le
ras-le-bol fiscal des ménages des
consommateurs et des entreprises c'est
une citation et le gouvernement nous
avait annoncé à un PLF pour 2014 qui
dont l'effort porterait à 80% sur la
dépense et à 20% sur la fiscalité mais
mais la lecture du projet loi de
finances pour 2014 montre que cette
présentation ne correspond absolument
pas la réalité la réalité la réalité des
chiffres c'est quoi la réalité des
chiffres ce que les dépenses du budget
général entre le PLF 2013
295,2 milliards d'euros et le PF pour
2014 294,
5 milliards d'euros la baisse des
dépenses n'étant réalité que de 700
millions 700 millions car vous devez
financer à sa demande de promesses
électorales et je pense en particulier
aux embauches un certain nombre de
ministère
la réalité des chiffres c'est la baisse
des dotations de l'État qui elle est
réelle un milliard 5 de baisse de
dotation pour les communes pour les
intercommunalités pour les départements
pour les régions moi 1,5 milliards
auquel doivent s'ajouter 2 milliards
d'euros de dépenses supplémentaires en
particulier pour les rythmes scolaires
on a parlé 2 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires c'est le chiffrage du
Comité des finances locales la réalité
c'est également pour le gouvernement une
hausse des cotisations d'impôts une
hausse des cotisations sociales qui va
concerner directement les entreprises je
pense bien sûr à l'IS qui va concerner
les ménages je pense à la TVA bref c'est
environ 12 milliards d'euros de
prélèvements supplémentaires pour les
français pour les familles en 2014 la
réalité c'est évidemment que les
Français ne croient plus à l'annonce
d'une pause fiscale que vous évoquez
d'ailleurs même plus les Français
attendent des réponses ils attendent des
réponses maintenant pour ce projet de
loi de finances pour Louis XIV il
n'annonce les attentes pas des
commentaires des critiques sur les
budgets précédents cela présente
mandature ils n'attendent pas non plus
des promesses pour les futurs budgets
ceux de 2015 ils attendent des réponses
pour maintenant et ma question est
extrêmement simple au cours de ce débats
budgétaire qui commence quelles dépenses
allez-vous accepter de réduire comme
vous y avez d'ailleurs le CDE et bien en
bref quelle réponse allez-vous apporter
aura le bol fiscal des Français merci
la parole est à Madame Fleur Pellerin
mini chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises
petit monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur je vous prie tout d'abord de
bien vouloir excuser Pierre Moscovici
que je suis plaie cet après-midi alors
nous pouvons séances après séance
rejouer sans cesse la même partition
avec sans cesse les mêmes questions et
donc toujours les mêmes réponses car
chaque semaine c'est la même question
que vous que vous nous posez et ce sont
les mêmes réponses que j'avais devoir
vous faire puisque vous en décidez ainsi
comme chaque semaine je serai dans
l'obligation de vous rappeler que
l'opposition est quand même bien prompte
assez exonéré de ses responsabilités à
l'heure de commenter la trajectoire
budgétaire de ce pays car les décisions
que nous prenons aujourd'hui ne sont
finalement que les répliques à votre
propre gestion et s'il y a des crochages
de l'économie française aujourd'hui il y
a il y a eu lieu hélas bien avant que
nous arrivions vous nous laissez un
déficit à 5,5% du PIB 600 milliards
d'euros de dettes supplémentaires un
commerce extérieur au plus bas alors oui
nous comment réparer et réparer au plus
vite et comme chaque semaine je vous
rappellerai que malgré malgré vous
malgré les Cassandre la situation
économique de notre pays s'améliore
progressivement tous les instituts
économiques le confirme la récession est
derrière nous la croissance revient
progressivement certes le chômage se
stabilise et nous le devons pour partir
à l'action de ce gouvernement comme
chaque semaine vous nous accusez de
matraquage fiscal laissant entendre que
si vous étiez resté au pouvoir les
choses auraient été tellement plus
douces et tellement plus simple vous
auriez su réduire les dépenses sans
heurter l'économie mais que n'avez-vous
fait pendant les dix années où vous avez
été au responsabilités vous auriez suivi
évité les hausse d'impôts mais alors
pourquoi ne pas avoir mis en pratique
cet engagement au cours des dernières
années la précédente majorité a voté
rien que pour les années 2011 et 2012
pas moins de 35 milliards d'impôts
supplémentaires alors comme chaque
semaine je vous rappellerai que la
dépense publique elle est désormais
maîtrisée nous intensifions même nos
efforts d'éc en 2014 un nez qui marquera
un basculement dans la répartition de
nos efforts entre recettes et dépenses
puis un Moscovici et Bernard Cazeneuve
ont élaboré un budget 2014 13 ambitieux
puisqu'il prévoit une baisse de 1,5
milliards d'euros de dépenses de l'État
or dette et pension c'est d'ailleurs la
première fois qu'un budget est construit
sur une base aussi ambitieuse je
rappelle que pendant le précédent
quinquennat pendant le précédent
quinquennat les dépenses ont progressé
en moyenne de 2 milliards d'euros par an
voilà votre bilan comme nous vous
l'expliquons depuis des semaines et
depuis des mois l'effort dorénavant et à
partir de 2015 se fera uniquement par
des économies et pour cela nous nous
donnons les moyens nous mettons en œuvre
les réformes structurelles qui ont été
évoquées par Marylise de branchu celle
que vous avez sans cesse reporté avec la
modernisation de l'action publique la
nouvelle étape de la décentralisation
l'action sur la sur les retraites et le
chantier de la simplification alors vous
le voyez monsieur le sénateurs
vous posez les mêmes questions nous
donnons les mêmes réponses et au fond
que faisons-nous si ce n'est ce que vous
n'avez su faire pendant 10 ans merci
merci